[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers and my
friends this is gunjan here
welcome to my fourth episode of killer
miniature straps
in today's lecture we are going to see
three different high profile quick
opening traps
and the content are as follows
the first trap i am going to show you is
a very special one because
recently i fall for this and to my
surprise
not many white players has chosen this
pass
so you can literally use this as a
complete surprise weapon
we have the sicilian defense on the
table after
c5 knight to f3 and knight to c6
rather than going into the main line of
d4
my opponent choose the move c3 a very
popular sideline
and leads to some of the strong allopine
structures
well i played the theoretical
recommendation that is
d5 and my point is after e catches d5
and queen captures d5 as white cannot
play knight to c3
my queen is well placed on the d5 square
okay white has to fight for the center
so he indeed played the move
d4 and accordingly black tried to
pressurize the center
with bishop to g4 pinning the knight
and trying to remove the defender of the
d4 square
well here by far the main line is bishop
to e2
however my opponent come up
with this very rare but very sneaky move
knight b to d2 and
at the time i still remember i said what
what was that from all
angle it looks like a blunder as black
is trying to pressurize the d pawn
and rather than defending white is
playing an
ugly move which apart from giving the
support to f3 knight
doesn't do anything
and because my opponent was low rated i
think
ok he made a big blunder i am going to
capture on d4
and after pawn takes d4
[Music]
here black should avoid capturing the d4
pawn
and continue with knight to f6 however
after bishop to c4 i think game remain
balanced
as both the side get their tactical
chances
but who can resist this free pawn
and just like me many many black players
has took this pawn instantly thinking
that
white has made a big error and now not
only black is a clear pawn
up but we are attacking the knight three
times and get more advantage
from this position
well guess what just one move
and blacks all dream shattered
and when in fact my opponent did played
the move queen to a4 check
suddenly to my surprise i realize
how crafty this trap is
came over guys because by force
white is winning a piece as if you
continue with
bishop to d7 then after queen captures
d4
white emerged with the whole knight up
and the other move knight to c6
completely fails
because of queen captures g4 and once
again
this time around white image with a
whole bishop
so this is one of the crafty trap in the
3c3 alpine
where instead of bishop to e2 here
you can literally surprise your opponent
especially in the quick game
with knight b to d2 and
punish your greedy opponent just within
the opening stage
the second trap occurs in the elephant
gambit
where the opening motors are as follow
e4 e5 knight to f3
and now rather than defending the e5
square black played this
tactical idea namely d5
okay by far the most popular choice is
he captures d5
and here black continued with e4
attacking the knight theory continue
with
queen to e2 pinning down that pawn
and attacking on e4 so black defended
with knight to f6 and now white put more
pressure
on the e pawn with d3
well now comes the move which sets up a
very cunning trap
and that is bishop to b4 check
here there are two popular choices one
is
c3 and second is bishop to d2
now if your opponent plays the move c3
then after
castle black get the huge initiative
and i have attached a sample game in the
pgn
so you can check it out but our main
trap occurs
when white plays the move bishop to d2
which looks more logical in this
position
idea is very obvious that if black took
this bishop
then after knight b to d2 white gain
more pressure
on the e4 spot
okay black castles at this point
and again if white plays the move d
captures e4
then after rook to e8 black get
huge attack especially on the e
file where white king and a queen
sitting there
so most of the white player has
considered the move
bishop captures b4 not only grabbing a
piece
but attacking that rook and in fact
few strong games has gone into this
direction
which i am afraid a completely wrong
idea
here white has straight away fallen into
the black trappy territory
and the trappy business start with this
very obvious move
he captures f3 attacking the queen
queen captures f3 and although
white has a bishop pair and few pawns he
is completely
losing from this position because of
this wonderful check
obviously if the king moves then that
clearly justify
the black's loss of pawn but you may ask
how about bishop to e2 isn't that
solve all white problem
nope not at all because just one
bishop to g4
and suddenly white can resign the game
as there is no way to defend on the e2
square
so this is one of the high profile trap
exist
in the elephant gambit which you
definitely want to consider
in your bloodscapes
the third high profile trap occurs after
the following
opening more order c4
e5 knight to c3
knight to c6 knight to f3
and now black plays the reverse grand
prix attack setup
starting with f5
well obviously white shouldn't allow the
space
and accordingly d4 is the best response
to whom black should gain more space on
the king's side
with e4
here the old theory suggests that bite
should go with this
knight maneuvering however
the modern approach is to play bishop to
g5
so getting rid of that bishop before we
close with
knight to d2
okay black continue with knight to f6
and now here white should play the moon
knight to d2
which if you look at first time looks
like a blunder
because can't black can simply take this
pawn
well of course he can but the big point
is
after knight captures e4 white
gained his material and this position
slightly
favors the white cam
but as happened many times sometimes
people don't know the theory
and there are few high profile games
continue with
d5 counter-attacking the black knight
and after this yup you guessed it
white has straight away fallen into the
black
trapezoid for a moment
it doesn't look like there is any trap
in this position
because after pawn takes f3 d takes c6
and pawn takes g2 yes
white cannot just simply take on g2
because after b capture c6
black emerged with an extra pawn
but he can continue with this
intermediate move
c captures d7 comes with a check
so that no matter however black
recapture in the next turn he can
capture on g2
and the remaining position looks quite
okay
well that will be the case if black
capture with queen or bishop
but to white surprise
black took the pawn with the knight
and now you see the beautiful idea
yes indeed black queen is hanging
but if white take the queen then
black can take the rook and promote a
new queen
so that is right out of the equation
and the base reply bishop captures g2
completely fails
because after simple queen captures g5
if you count the material black emerge
with a clear piece advantage
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
three high profile mini traps
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care